hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation we
just got over a very sad part of the
game and we're moving forward to try to
finish this story I don't know how close
I am to the end I may be very far away
from it I have no idea but I know that I
need to talk to an AI to him to disable
all of the rogue Androids on this ship
because there are now only Android
finally someone who knows what's up
about this stupid robot situation oh I
suppose to be there sorry wrong room
there anything in here that I need a
bunch of supplies that I can't craft
anything out of anymore but I know that
I need to move forward and I need to do
something with that green dot so I'm
gonna act like I know what I'm doing
what's most of what I do and every oh
right in front of me didn't see it so
many things that are right in front of
me wanted because I'm trying to look at
myself in the camera and see how
handsome I am and I do not anticipate
that there's gonna be something that I
need right there okay keep going the
forward
yep
okay we'll do very quickly let me just
find where the hell does gonna be is
this what I'm supposed to do something
about a fan or an exhaust fan or some
sort of fan I believe maybe it was in
another area maybe was nearby maybe
there's gonna be a bit of a clue that's
gonna tell me hey I need to get to the
core of the mainframe oh it's on the
other side I'm my bad I thought that it
was gonna be in the same area where I
just was I have no idea that I was gonna
be tossed around like a rag doll okay so
I know he said whoa okay that looks hot
hot as hell so I need to find a way to
cool that down or can I go right in
oh no can't go in listen number one do
not dive face-first into superheated
steam it's generally bad for you Apollo
Sales one cheat why an Apollo system for
your deep-space orbital stations self
regulation and Android maintenance
security through removal of synthetic
self-determination instinct
communication no interference lightning
fast data movement across the station
reliable efficient self-sustaining a
true cigs and products also totally free
of charge it'll murder every one of your
staff get tons of insurance money I must
have read through just about every
single one of those things by now how
many more thoughts could people on this
station possibly have okay so I was down
here somewhere
I'm gonna find it come out come out
wherever you are
so this then okay so I need to turn this
off and then I'm guessing I'm going into
this superheated room it was right over
there I didn't have to go far at all
okay so now that that is all done
creaking relax we should be clear okay
Ronin I was running way long ago
Birmingham ladder yes climb baby five
fast it's about to get hot in here take
a finite Clause this is gonna be oh
that's what she said yeah he was pretty
badass and I liked it a lot it's a damn
shame what they did done stupid Apollo
has something to answer for that damn
synthetic killed my damn synthetic boo
I'm coming too okay I need to access
Apollo human staff entrance well I'm
basically human so the Apollo poor is
locked
I'm on my own he just told you there was
going to be interference from the radio
you're too far down in the station cuz
apparently is one of those stations that
doesn't have inner spiritual
communication between everything
nevermind
Apollo would ask you for your patience
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's good I swear I thought a face
hugger was coming right at my face
oh hello sorry goodbye you didn't see
anything did you okay so I need to do
something to get over there that goes
straight to Apollo but do I need to go
to human consultation control first find
a policy when consultation control room
so going into the Corps would be bad it
is that would you sing well I won't have
a word with this Apollo whoever he
thinks he or she or it may be I don't
have time but I do have time to shoot a
lot of people in the face so bring it on
your Android deuces
you killed Sanders I'm not happy about
that oh goodness that's new mr.
sousaphone man so you want some of that
song oh oh my guns are gone oh I had so
much confidence a little bit ago oh god
that's why all the things are bad I
thought I totally forgot I completely
forgot
oh I forgot everything turned [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god
Oh guys you don't know nothing breathe
you don't know nothing about nothing
help
you're the friend gave up why don't you
go with them I think you need to hold
his hand on the way to the bathroom okay
I totally forgot I had no weapons that
was really really dumb of me it's only
you I played yesterday and I was really
tired at the end of it I forgot that I
put my weapons on the conveyor belt and
like all just smacked me right in the
face at once I'm going to die I cannot
shoot this guy in the face didn't
explain why I couldn't go oh he was
wearing a rubber protective suit that
was probably okay I'm about to hack into
this mainframe Oh leap hacker style
there's no way you can get my get in my
way
some insult to Apollo I can't good what
does that mean search the left server
bank ship sure barber sure Burbank
console oh I'm supposed to be both okay
well I'll just do them one at a time
then why don't I so I need to be
I need even high alert for those things
because they could be anywhere like
right there
good good thing they can't hear these
really loud doors
okay whoever the hell Suzanne is that
guy whoever well that guy is loves you
very much and I do too oh I'm not in the
right place oh I thought I was in the
room already I I just didn't realize
that this was actually just an accessory
to the crime what I do have is a bunch
of these things I'm guessing in the EMP
mind the IMP mine would be good for
taking out those douchebags so I just
got to be nice there's a lot of water in
there are you sure you want to be
walking around
that's bad music use okay
we're gonna get no one that was quick
[Music]
nothing Hey
I'm not running we can't go up the
ladder oh I did not know damn it
I'm not running you you shut up you're
running to see the break eye contact for
a little bit there creepy creepy eye
contact that's really creepy why do you
have to be so creepy that wasn't the
right one I'd rather not I'm gonna put
this right here i'ma run the hell over
this way you're gonna blow the hell up
how about that
over here
Dindin time fresh little pipe bomb god
you're not dead
how are you not dead oh you're suck
oh whatever it worked I don't even
understand this anymore you're gonna be
blinded by the light boy danboy oh that
does well that did nothing oh oh oh
creepy you're so creepy so what do I do
oh okay all these are for killing not to
you guys
I want my weapons oh this bad oh god
you're so creepy
I don't think I'll be able to do this
quickly enough what about if I - I'm
gonna smoke you out what do I do
okay yes oh this works SB no one sees me
oh you see me well that's a problem god
this is gonna take a while
bear with me everybody
now they'll be all looking all the way
hey what was that noise over there and
they'll never think to look at me right
over here on the damn computer let's
just click the thing dad I know
freedom yes
do i you bastards good i wasted a bunch
of pipe bombs to try to blow you up
that's why it was loading me up with the
supplies because who knew that I
wouldn't have a gun I guess that's good
[Applause]
well mr. ranchers finally get a little
angry around here I saw that there was
DLC announced for this game where you
get to play as ransom I don't know why
I'd want to do that from what I've heard
he's a bit of a dick but then again
maybe he has a silver lining to his
story or maybe he gets mauled horribly
by the alien is there someone in here I
don't know what this is gonna do but I
think I'm in the brain core alright that
is how much on the world what what how
do you oh oh I need to find a way to
reduce Paulo's security capabilities
first and foremost before I do any of
that this looks interesting
what is that a quiet room that he's
supposed to have it's quiet
don't don't talk the big artificial
brain is dreaming of Electric Sheep
that's the quote Do Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep that was the name of a
book I don't know if that was the name
of the book - originally whoa I was off
in la-la land
that's helpful he wasn't even looking at
me
how can I screw up more how can I screw
up more it didn't combust at all you
hope
yeah yeah you do your thing let's be
over here not being suspicious hey catch
gosh why should I calm down you're about
to kill me I'm going to catch you know
no running causes shut the hell up are
you gonna burn to death or what don't
don't cut me off don't don't don't don't
this is exactly what I did on Ripley
does not like you douche okay time for
my secret ninja Jitsu thing you never
never gonna know all the smoke it
obscures your vision and now the coup de
Gras flashbang over there or over here
you will be an accident okay I'm totally
in the clear now that took awhile
yeh whatever the hell I did it's doing
it now
[Music]
and what tale did that do you're making
you waste human life okay so that should
have done enough to cool I'm sure you're
misunderstanding what are you doing
where you going oh no okay I'm gonna run
for it because you guys just suck huh no
I got it okay press matching move Keys
one circuit is active okay
okay I got it that was a little fun but
I got it it was like a DDR type thing I
didn't know that there were symbols over
on the left side that showed what keys
they were but I got it now okay so I did
that I pushed that button so I should be
able to go in the tunnel over there do
the puzzle there and then push the
button
Boop okay so that's that and then I
should go in here be able to do this
clear up the security and then I should
be able to talk to Apollo or at least
that's my so oh god highlight values
entered to confirm okay then
oh boy okay I think is that what I'm
supposed to do yep yeah I don't know if
that was a secret engineering school
hacking deal same with the secret
engineering school smoke disappearing
trick ah but good enough for me okay
let's do this let's dance Apollo it's me
and my little hacker tool against you
and your ugly stupid actually you're
probably very smart so my insults aren't
doing too good here I am good
okay so with the ball oh here we go hey
you got some Antron to do you got some
explaining to do don't you tell me you
see oh god you're a big you're bigger
than I thought you were
it's exterior okay so now that go hollow
whoa everybody both in the brain
this is what it takes to make an a stop
in the damn brain is whoa cutscene I'm
about to go in mind of Apollo that's all
this is a chair in a computer terminal
oh whoa
what is the system shock holy crap this
is so system shock right now yeah
negative whoa the hell weyland-yutani
stepping in on SIG's enough
[Music]
[Music]
uh-huh yeah okay well that's interesting
does that mean that the alien is here or
maybe there's more to this than I think
there is I'm gonna go with that option
come on what happened
what'd you do do it again I didn't see
all the viewers out there they want to
say don't you want to see guys what the
hell okay so there must be some other
way it said beneath the core so exit
Apollo beneath the war why oh that's
what happened okay so that's the cool
thing didn't we
Thanks whoa hostile takeover of Sikhs in
huh very hostile
so the androids were just to stop people
from leaving or escaping or trying to
let the specimen escape or trying to
stop the specimen for being kill
murdered protect the specimens as if the
specimen needed to be protected at all
okey-dokey then where am I here we go
Apollo primary interaction law human
interaction request for inner corporate
messaging received out luli outgoing
message to weyland-yutani representative
accepted and monitored colonial March
today an incident report
temporary emergency measures initiated
medical purchase order received will and
yutani operational rule set packet
verified and installed emergency
measures measures initiated in San
Cristobal medical facility extended no
further information provided gay
unverified scans and reactor systems
special order 939 initiated priority 1
protect specimen oh my goodness new
inhabitants logged with Apollo systems
by synthetic staff Ripley Amanda level 2
weyland-yutani de leur nina level 4
weyland-yutani Samuels Chrissa 4
three weyland-yutani so Taylor was
actually the highest-ranking
weyland-yutani official there she was in
charge a viable threat to specimen
detected in project cave g3 for eight
hazard lab containment hazard level
alert raised to Omega so that was where
we injected the specimen right
I imagine spreading spending its ransom
with the weyland-yutani buyout it's some
more important than ever that the flight
recorder handover goes without a hitch
there'll be low-level execs and won't
know jack about the buyout but if they
hear rumors about a disappearing people
problem well I don't want to rock the
boat and neither do you
let's just keep everything nice and
quiet and we don't want them having
second thoughts okay there's a Bering
Babel problem hey forget it just gloss
over a day they get lost all the time
it's a big station Waianae yeah
engineering whoo I get to go to
engineering now my place of education I
was a biomedical engineer before I did
YouTube know if you knew that maybe
you've seen my draw my life I talk about
a bit there or I've mentioned in pretty
much everything I knew
why am i whispering
yeah that sounds about right
I mean I guess tailor was only level 4 I
don't know how many levels it oh god I
saw I see like these shimmers in the
distance that I remember that anime from
the evil within the one that turned
invisible I don't like it I don't much
care for it how do I get to that save
point oh I can't get to that same point
okay so what am I supposed to do now the
point of interest right in front of me
this thing here it's oh I got a restore
power but that's the thing that I do to
restore power i crank the thing three
times and then I push a button it's all
I know how to do I'm just an engineer
okay so this goes to something huh
what did what did I did what in the
world did okay I think that restored
enough power that I can crank this yank
and push the button Hey oh I'm
activating the tram that's what that
said sorry I wouldn't buy that pretty
quickly so this means that I'll be able
to get out of here or where am I going
now I feel like I may have lost my
purpose somewhere after I went to a bowl
that the tram
okay that makes more sense now I can
save ya good for me hey I'm busy
IRL encounters I will be with you in a
moment
too busy recording awesome videos for my
lovely fans out there who are awesome
and amazing give yourself a random
applause dark clapping in the comments
below
just type clap over and over good enough
for me people might get confused that
and that's good you want people confused
okay okay so about that restricted
access I am an engineer so you know
here's my theory about what I'm gonna
find down there because they want to
protect the specimen but there was a
priority threatened there's something in
the reactor whoa don't be so damn creepy
a dick I don't have my guns can't it's a
lot more creepy when something you there
that you can't kill that's an intense
music okay so I need to turn the camera
feed off air purification on okay that's
good enough for me so neither cameras
off oh I saw a body watch you red
glowing eyes yeah ooh that's handy big
cloud of smoke good enough for me no one
will be able to detect my presence does
a blueprint here blueprint no it looks
like a brute plan but I baking over the
LV
Oh something's gonna jump out of the
darkness this is one of those moments
that's the thing oh this is the thing
innit
I'm going in here I don't care if
there's a Linda near we're okay things
are getting a little weird what's I mean
seriously what's with the ominous music
why does it need to be sodium ominous
Android any murderous Androids
am I even going the right way I'm no
idea to engineering floor get to the
reactor I guess I need to go this way so
that is what I'll do these boots were
made for walking so that's just what
they'll do if I could have just one gun
I really liked having a gun
oh now I get the ion torch well I mean I
guess I will have to cycle oh that look
there's a heavy-duty flashlight do I not
want that or something now I will be
able to cycle back to everything and
finally on undo the doors on those ion
torch things you know even I don't know
what I'm talking about anymore oh no no
no no no no it's not cool
no no no no no no no no no no no Mookie
all right we're good we're good we're
good all right now all right now don't
want to set off any alarms and I'd have
to be on the run which might actually be
a better thing I mean I don't need to
worry about the noise correct correct
that's I mean if the noise was really
something that I was gonna be worried
about then the alien that would mean the
alien was back or maybe there's baby
aliens crawling around all over the
place I mean that alien was not a queen
let's just be frank that alien was a
normal standard grunt alien oh good shut
down the whole thing
I mean whoa right I want one of these
things I really do it's like a portable
lightsaber I mean I like gadgets this is
my thing I'm one of a dude to him an
engineer three I'm a nerd for I'm a dork
five I'm a geek I'm like super duper
addicted to technology
that's what I want to be in space so bad
I want to know that we can do it I want
to meet the intellectual challenges I
wanna go boldly well no one have boldly
gone before I shouldn't be in charge of
anything though I would just screw it up
I'd be standing on the front of the deck
like I would make it so that there's
like one of those crows nests up top of
the old ships but I put that on a space
ship and I'd just be a player I crazy
mark again he's at it again third time
this week
and then everyone would die and that's
the end of the story and then I found
$5.00
cool huh is that a tank uh this guy
gonna see in here or something
wait I'm outside the workshop why did I
need to come back around here I need to
get to the reactor they're like an
elevator over there than I need looks
like there might be hey buddy hey buddy
I bet you're not immune to the stun
baton like those other dudes were whoa
maybe I don't need why do you need to
cycle through your sales pitch number
one creepy number two you're stupid
number four I would never buy you
well how did I do that oh it's my bad
habit of pressing every button I see hi
okay this is gonna work on you because
you're not protected gonna fall over and
sorry about that needed to happen
alright thank you
Oh power level too low so is this one
where I need the cur chunk or the thing
oh so there's gonna be a series of him
now so I asked it was better that I just
killed the dude okay so how is that now
I need to get the other one and then I
can push the button I don't know what
kind of power these guys are running on
let's go to weird oh there's another one
right here shut up listen to your stupid
music whatever is playing in the station
still okay there's one up here gimme
gimme I did it I did it you good
one more come on
everything's okay turn on the power and
nothing else happened it sounds like I'm
powering up sousaphone man to play more
horror music behind me caboose key okay
so this should get me into the reactor
the fights invalid we are talking about
the device's invalid oh I guess I need
to upgrade my security tuner eventually
I guess okay
well that's really cool that I lifted
that up I'm so glad that that happened
so oh very cool huh did not know did not
see cannot see very dark
okay still not monsters in here okay I'm
gonna find what's going on in this
reactor I really do think that when I
get to the reactor it's got to be just a
bunch of eggs like there's some other
Queen here now this is like the soldier
going around then there's another one
cuz I mean that species it's supposed to
be able to create its own like reproduce
all of everything all in one am i doing
where the hell my it feels like I'm just
going in a big circle like it puts that
objective near me and then it's like oh
come on this is like this is totally
back to where I was
oh no it's not oh okay I was misled I
did not trust I need to learn to trust
again unlock this shutter how am I gonna
do that
oh oh that's the reactor access shudder
so I should be able to go over here and
there should be like eight terminal of
some sort it's gonna tell me exactly
what I need whoa was it what did I get I
just got something I think it said bolt
done and we're gonna get a bolt gun am I
gonna get a nail gun I almost blew my
cover I did not see what that was again
you sound really weird I don't like you
so why does this not do what it's
supposed to do this is supposed to
disable those things isn't it it's an
EMP mind supposed to disable electronics
so why am I not able to do it I guess a
smoke bomb was a little more useful than
the other
must play now is that because they need
to be eliminated
is that what you're trying to tell me oh
it's my bouncy friend what am I gonna do
about this guy hey what was that noise
what the Oh No
okay we're okie okie dokie my little
buddy what I did not intend to do that
yes now we're really getting the dead
space territory but I want to do this
first because we need it done there was
children read through the emails really
quickly so I can get the coudé six eight
three two okay that's easy enough it's
good oh damn it not again you want to
get a bolt gun Oh God
fine you know what you want to throw
down it's time to throw down I got a
bolt gun I don't know what the hell does
he guess what hi friend is it
whoa how's the music didn't work at all
I don't have a lot of ammo for this I
don't know waste it just wanted to try
it though wanna I really want to see
what the hell this does your face
watch.watch in that way was that good
okay you know what I'm not gonna waste
ammo for this thing this is to pose
point-blank why don't you shut up and
get hit in the face with a bolt cut
whatever I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm going to catch you no you're not I
refuse
you shall not I am out of here
oh good finally come on now got a flimsy
ass bolt gun that ain't gonna do jack oh
there we go thank you thank you I gotta
get to the central reactor I gotta go go
go it's really hot in this room I'm
sweating up a storm
it seems like a lifetime wait what kind
of reactor are we talking about kind of
reactor would have people have a tour
through that does not seem fun give me a
lot more bold ammo I want that I want to
be able to shoot something in the face
even when I'm point-blank away I wanna
shaadi oh my good friend shaadi shotgun
yeah and a revolver kept all my ammo
well that's handy okay whatever you know
what whatever I'm not gonna come Lane I
got my weapons back I'm gonna shoot you
that was a little son don't do that to
me this game it's game it just wants the
dick with me this one's the deck with me
yes
okey-dokey so okay dark and creepy
corridor leading to the reactor one Oh
what are wait wait school sci-fi tech is
literally the best oh hey I'm not sure
if I remember this being from the
original like the aliens the sequel I
know they look a lot like the things
from Star Wars when they were flying
into the Death Star and blowing it up
that's what it looks like but goddamn I
love old school like technology
especially when it comes to power
because it's inspired by a Nikola
[ __ ] and all that stuff and you'll see
like so many of the electricity is
shooting everywhere Tesla coils all
sorts of cool stuff like that no concept
of how it's creating electricity all
that it is it just is so don't even
worry about it don't even concern your
pretty head with it it's just doing its
job oh I think I have to shoot these
guys hey buddy
toughy ancient I'm gonna get backed into
a corner here that's not gonna be reload
reload come on come on oh that was too
close Dan Akaka
let's wait chuckles oh god more coming
oh God
time to switch to the shotty God takes
forever I can't I can't bump up dinky
how about this for some basketball savvy
[Music]
that why okay these guys are just
tougher okay I'm gonna run right by you
because at least you're slower so I'm
not gonna shoot you
you come over here
Oh kiss you're becoming ugh - upstairs
upstairs he's getting over there this
much faster well why do I hear the
screams of the Damned oh this is so
final I love it it made a core primer
okay primer sounds good I think I need
to do that it's all Sikhs and tech alpha
core primer does that mean that I need
to do that first I'll support primary
after core primer Alpha Beta Alpha Beta
Alpha Beta awesome oh so kick-ass
everything about is awesome okay about
what am I needed to do I don't even know
descend to the base of reactor okay so I
don't even need to be here yet I just
need to go down to the base of it oh so
cool it hurts how cool it is okay what
do you got for me what do you got for me
yeah I just need to watch out for those
guys on the way back I mean I'm sure
they'll forget about me and there's a
lot of room to run there but I can't let
him get me because that's gonna be the
end of Ripley we're not near to the end
of the game yet at least I don't know
sound of gun I can summon the alien you
talk a lot about the alien but the alien
isn't here anymore in a wishing whoa
I so cold
oh good I get to burn everything to the
ground okay that's already open now I
need to burn that they're all here yeah
next there are exits
okay okay oh that guy got to work whoa I
knew this had to happen at some point
it's always gotta have this part in it
oh my dad that alien is so much fun oh
god I got to rewatch all the movies now
I just gotta I can't not at this point
though the battery's out whoa whoa oh
god I thought he was gonna pop out of me
does this mean that there are literally
hundreds of aliens running around
because that seems that's right
curl up and die these things don't like
fire I know that I know you there
yeah that's right burn up burn down to
the ground these things are very
flammable I appreciate that
Oh
ha sorry I got a bit of a cough okay so
that guy blew up nice and good yeah
ethanol where am I going down there okay
overload the apple core this is where
I'm supposed to be isn't it
Oh disengage locking mechanism okay I'll
activate alchemy okay may have all
reacted a little bit but he's dead whoa
whoa
they're giving me ethanol because I know
they want me to make Molotov cocktails
yep Dolf bunk okay so that's got there
and go around to the other side and do
whatever needs to be done
come on her chunker's okay that was one
I'm sure there needs to be another one
done here we're about to be overloaded
okay I don't know what I got I keep
clicking before I actually read
it's as bad okay well that looks really
cool am I supposed to be staring at it
God that is cool oh so cool oh it's so
cool Wow I should not be this close to
that thing
lieutenant what if it said negligence
yeah I need I need a bed kid real bad it
did the thing where it didn't put the
thing why did it go to the stun baton
well screw you it's being sure to search
the bodies of the dead before I get in
there yeah yeah that's right burn okay
those are both burnin turn this off able
conduit should be able to do this
quickly now now that I'm not being dumb
oh oh that was a flashlight battery okay
so a flashlight better now I should be
this junk okay get over there do this
trunk okay done and done
the cool thing is gonna happen but I'm
not gonna stand around look at it this
time because I've already seen it now oh
now I need to walk quietly because now
things are about to get pretty bad cuz
now the aliens are back finally and I'm
willing to bet that there are a lot of
them now like that's why they had
trouble killing the one no it's not good
it's almost as if everything wants to
keep you dear
Oh God it's not gonna let me save is it
okay so I need to go up
[Music]
yeah movement am I in the right place
I'm not am i okay I need to go through
that tunnel burn up baby run away a big
pansy that's right run away
Oh God Oh God oh hi this is getting
horrible okay wrong way
the things got awful real quick
sure was that gonna save back no no no
no no that's right that's right
you better run yeah I'm not gonna use a
med kit this time so you got me myself
back to the flamethrower yeah yeah I
know
[Music]
watch now oh this is the end this is
horrible he's gonna take forever
I'm gonna be dead I'm gonna be so dead
I am so dead oh he's not gonna go well
oh this is not gonna go well let me just
college just cut back to where I was
before be right back well someone's not
happy about something okay here we go so
this sign with a little more stealth and
a little more eye out for the creepy
crawlies I definitely don't want to be
ambushed and face hugged that's like the
bat I keep thinking that there's one
sneaking up behind me hello sir
is that does that moisture dripping from
there just because it's moist here I
don't think there's a dude there Peter
skitter skitter
that's right Oh Mama's upset whoa whoa
whoa they have grown a tolerance to the
flamethrower a little bit at least our
guy was way too close for me to have my
wave okay what the negs opening
everything's cracking and creaking it's
not good not good not good yeah where
does this lead this does not lead to
where I need to go I need to go the
other way
well both oh god with the thing why does
that still surprise me no not this time
baseball baby use a medkit quick okay I
mean it's one at this son you're gonna
get me not this time
that might be I don't know there's so
much drool coming out of everywhere I
don't know it's a surprise ambusher
what's just normal okay
I could have sworn that guy would know I
was here considering I shine my
flashlight on him
Oh another same point how convenient
maybe they understand that this all is
very bad for my health
oh oh oh
broken it was probably another creepy
crawly around here
Bulls closed
going was that cop damn it again with
the explosion now welcome here okay
disengage locking mechanism where the
hell is the locking mechanism this one
where's locking mechanism where the hell
is the locking mechanism baited cork
conduit where the hell does this lead
I guess there's just too much saliva all
the walls cuz my framerate just dipped a
little bit well that's a bad sound he
doesn't know me though well he will soon
okay so if I go down that way it's gonna
loop back to where I was but I got to
overload the beta core but damn where's
the override where the hell is the
override oh boy
where the hell is the locking Megan here
god damn it how could I not see this
this was right now well no power god
damn it how many things do you want me
to do in this game
oh I don't much appreciate all of this I
do not okay alright okay we're okay so
far that's bad
it doesn't know I'm here
doesn't know it doesn't know okay so I
have to end this episode here okay so
I'm gonna pause it here I have done this
episode but thank you all so much for
watching I'm gonna pick it right back up
this got awesome again with aliens don't
know why I asked for it so much now I
don't want it so thanks again everybody
and as always I will see you
[Music]
[Music]